he's on brother from another uh
pinch-hitting for another from brother
from another and i will be on brother
from another later on today does that
make all sense to everybody yes um now
batting for michael holly
scheduled to appear michael smith smith
smith how are you michael how are you
sir
we're we're all brothers is what it
really comes down to i agree that's
basically
very rarely is an interview also a
pre-interview for the interviewer
right so what do you want what do you
what are we going to talk about later
on the show we're a week from football
man okay good week out okay very good i
mean they're good so we can't we can't
get hype enough
for football i understand um
you've been uh
helping out brian flores pump up to a
tongue about
i am caping for him yes michael smith i
am um
no judgment and i'm sure it endears you
to a lot of dolphins fans too
so i would take it from your uh approach
here um on what i'm what you're putting
down i i appear to feel like i'm picking
up that you you are not believing that
tua is a starting quarterback in the nfl
for the dolphins or oh
too much okay
all right i never said he's not a
starting quarterback okay what do you
got
i would just say that i completely
understand now okay
out of the obligatory moment where we
say
and we can come back to this of course
of course but the obligatory moment
where we say setting aside
all of deshaun watson but you can't
you can't that's the point
but for purpose is what i'm about to say
i can okay but i'll say we'll come back
to it but this for purposes is what i'm
about to say okay setting aside the
sexual assault allegations all right
i completely understand why an
organization
would want to upgrade from to a tonga by
law to a desean watson i mean not not
everybody who has a young quarterback is
looking to acquire desean watson but i
think the
the jury is still out onto a tongue
about lower in a way that it is not for
joe burrow for example even though he's
coming off an injury in a way that is
not obviously for justin herbert who
looks like he's a budding superstar okay
the jury's still on him because and i
and i think the questions come from
within because into a tongue of a low
end granny was coming off of an injury
and he was a rookie quarterback but the
questions come from within the way that
brian flores handled him last year when
he was bashing him in the second half in
favor ryan fitzpatrick some of the
albeit anonymous quotes that came out of
the locker room about whether or not he
was the guy and the other thing that is
unfair to a tongue about lower
is not only are we less inclined to
allow quarterbacks to develop and
experience the growing pains that so
many quarterbacks start history have had
to go through
is the dolphins almost overnight went
from tanking fortuna
uh to where a quarterback away and so
when you're a quarterback away
that's that much less patience that
people tend to have and then you bring
in the desean watson um
pursuit which is real from the top down
um
i think that's why
two is kind of by comparison when you're
starting to compare him to it desean
watson again on the field i think that's
what two or maybe
doesn't get
the respect that some dolphins fans
would like to see him get i don't think
he's earned it yet i don't think he's
earning just by virtue of being the
fifth pick and you know
uh winning games at alabama um
so that's all i'm not saying he's not a
start i'm not saying he can't be good
but going into the desean part if i may
um unless you want to you want to go
ahead and cut me off there no no no no
no i do want to chime in um so let me
and later on when i'm on your show i'll
do my best to take the control freak out
of the host position so yeah and i'll uh
but but i i do want to jump in here
though and say to you
that in my caping yesterday
uh in the same way that you had your
caveat of removing 22
civil cases that hang over him and the
entire process and whatever else is the
we don't know what we don't know we
think we know everything and and grand
jury and all of that stuff
that that i
i am
in removing that as well
have would have had no problem the
dolphins being the first calling nick
casario the minute he was hired and
desean watson sent out that cryptic
tweet that did actually mean that he was
very displeased with texans management
and in that period of january all the
way through to the time that we learned
that there were charges coming his way
civilly yeah i would have absolutely
agreed that the dolphins would have
turned to if you will into josh rosen i
would not have i would have told like if
watson all things being equal
totally
get it
i don't get the pursuit of the
everything together because that's the
way life is that you can't separate all
of that i don't get the pursuit of that
right now on the outset of a season
with tua that was what my said what i
said and and i don't understand where
the doubt about tua comes from i think
i've put a
uh a good grasp on it which i'm more
than happy to unpack with you
um you know because i have thought as
you might imagine a lot about this
so you know if you want to hop back in
here let's let's have that conversation
you know well i would like to hear more
about the the not understand where the
doubt comes from but going back to the
pursuit of desean um
look i
i i do get it and i think i can say that
i get being enamored with deshawn all
things considered now we're not
separating anything all things
considered
because
based on
what it
isn't so far we know how bad it looks so
based on what it isn't so far
if you have an opportunity
to get a quarterback that in the short
term it may be
difficult uncomfortable hell he may not
be available you may uh you know a
segment of your fan base
may not
want him around they may be completely
sickened by these accusations and
allegations
but in the long term
you got a top five quarterback
for the long term
um
and eventually he's going to play
football again he's going to be
available to play football again he's
going to somewhere why not miami if
you're miami right
so i understand that pursuit looking at
the big picture saying okay if he's gone
for four games or eight games or hell
even all this season if we can get him
at the right price
if we can get a depressed asset at the
right price who wants to be here and
only here
why not do it because he's clearly an
upgrade over to her all things being
equal
the flip side is for me
and this is where i draw the ire of of
texans twitter
is
for the same reason that if you're and i
heard you say this for the same reason
if you're the dolphins why in the world
would you give up three ones and two
twos for a guy with 22 civil uh
civil complaints and 10 criminal
complaints and three different
investigations against them is the same
reason why i don't believe that texans
can afford to take the posture of
oh we'll just trade him for more in
march we'll just hold on to him and
we'll get more when all this is sorted
out well how do you know it's going to
be sorted out
like how do you exactly know how it's
going to play out it could play out
worse number one number two not going to
play for you again so he may be a
franchise quarterback he's not your
franchise quarterback number three he
has a no trade clause which complicates
things and last but not least and this
is what will pass it back to you rich
eisen
going back to your tour opinion let's
say you're right and everybody has
cracked onto a completely unfairly and
unjustly and he is not getting you know
the the benefit of the doubt that he
deserved that his second year freaking
quarterback was coming off a devastating
hit hip injury his last year at alabama
right with no preseason last year you
know no real off season covey no you
don't hear no excuses for two were
talking about lower it's just let's just
get somebody better oh we missed we
didn't get borough and we should have
taken her but we missed right you never
hear that what if tour is that dude and
what if two of balls out this year
and what if he's great and then brian
flores and steven ross and chris grill's
like you know what who sometimes i need
to trade your mate sometimes the ones
you don't make right so we're gonna just
keep our draft picks keep our young
quarterback on his rookie contract
there's one less suitor what if he man
aaron rodgers is on the market next year
and denver's like hey eric you're still
interested bam now aaron rodgers in
denver they got sam you got sam howell
you got spencer rattler you got all
these different quarterbacks coming out
next year
okay you have five in the first round
this year you got more coming out next
year that that game of quarterback
musical chairs not saying nobody would
want desean watson don't get me wrong
i'm simply saying the marketplace could
look a lot different and you may not
have as many or the obvious suitors
willing to give you the price that you
think you should get for an asset who's
not an asset to you if he ain't playing
for you well the bottom line is michael
smith of brother from another here on
the rich eisen show is it looks like one
of the most talented players in the
league
um at the the as he's still ascending in
his talent is going to be sitting
in deshaun watson and i i just can't
wrap my arms around that one man but
it's it's
i mean we showed his death chart we
showed the texans death chart earlier
he's third on the death chart he's
because it's crazy
he's really like legitimately
purposefully being scratched into
uh
into oblivion right now in in houston i
i
i don't know how the hell it got to this
point i i honestly thought it would be
over and it would be
wrapped up and
we would know what was going on with
these cases and and the conversation
would be well what did desean really say
or do and what how real was all this as
we're watching him ball out for another
franchise instead it's completely
different
i'm glad you know initially i know i was
making a point so i'm glad you'd push
back earlier because it's like you don't
ever want to separate the very real very
serious allegations right
from the football that's that's a
disservice
to the victim you know and i've always
tried not to center the victims excuse
me or the alleged victims of begging
pardon the accusers um
it's a disservice to them and i've
always tried not to center the
quarterback in these conversations about
sean watson but having said that that's
from a football and a business
standpoint because the games and the in
the business still does go on that's why
i think if you're houston
i get one to maximize it but i also want
i'd also want this to be somebody else's
problem at this point but that's why
nicosia will get all the money he's
getting
and you know sure he's got a a good idea
of of how he wants this thing to play
out so but no i mean it's it's it is
it's incredible that it has gotten to
this point
um
to see to see somebody who
just a couple of years ago
was going toe-to-toe with patrick
mahomes
is not even a factor
uh in the league crazy right now it's
crazy brother from another michael smith
right here in the rich eisen show and
i'll i'll bring the two of stuff to your
show later on i'll i'll i want to chop
it up with you there because i want to
put a pin in that for the moment what
else you want to talk about i want to
know what you thought about the ben
simmons report that he'll he'll play for
anybody but the sixers and what embiid
was tweeting about yesterday
where he was denying there was a rift
between the two um and i guess part of
that comes from him
uh being very honest in the post-game
press conference first blush i'm sure he
had his emotions running wild after
being eliminated and
simmons passing up the bunny dunk um and
that was kind of the last straw with
everybody in philadelphia what what did
you make of all that yesterday you know
if maybe this is this is who i am i'm
just like i'm not one of these people in
my in in in a pretend world an alternate
timeline in the multiverse where i
actually am able to live out my dream of
being a gm okay yes
um i'm just not the type of gm
in my head
franchise mode mike okay i'm not the
kind of guy
who looks at situations in terms of well
i have a 25 year old defensive player of
the year runner up multiple time
all-star all-nba team selection who's a
gifted pastor an excellent defender and
i am going to get
heaven and earth for him
no i look at it like
okay he's not a good fit here
he's probably
if he can fix his shooting woes
probably ain't gonna happen on the
timetable we want it to happen or we've
seen no indication that
he can he can fix it or is truly
committed to fixing it in the time that
he's been here okay and whether or not
we lose the team one of the team blah
blah blah my man had eight six and five
points not to mention after the game doc
rivers and joel embiid they said the
truth out loud okay so it is clearly
uncomfortable and perhaps even untenable
to return ben simmons here
so similar as i was saying about nick
casario ironically i would talk about a
former houston rocket ship and daryl
mori
it's like if i'm daryl mori i'm not
trying to get for who do i think i am
asking for four first-round picks
and two and two players an all-star
player for a dude that can't come back
here and now ben simmons has made it
that much more difficult by making it
clear i'm holding out
which is what every other team was
probably banking on like you know what
this will get messy for them this will
get worse before it gets better because
they got to get rid of ben simmons so i
blame daryl mori for having not moved on
from this problem long time ago instead
of trying to hold hold the situation
hostage and act like oh it's all good i
just so happen to want to trade ben
simmons the same dude i want to trade
last year for james harden
understandably so but the same dude i
want to trade last year
acting like you don't have to trade him
he should be more desperate to make the
trade than other teams are to get ben
simmons so lower your asking price get
him up out of there and it maybe you
don't get
well you're not gonna get a hundred
pennies on the dollar for him
he's just not at least not in the short
term it may not seem that way but you
get a better fitting roster there was a
report that it was malcolm brogdon in
the first
at one point now maybe one first round
people not enough but give me that i'll
take that in a second
you know like that's probably probably
not going to do a whole lot better than
that under the circumstances you see
what i'm saying so
and b was just doing the thing he had to
do in case ben simmons comes back like
hey my name is paul that's between y'all
my name is ben and i ain't in it you
know we're teammates i love him we're
good don't look at me it's not my fault
right
doc will probably do something similar
to me daryl mori should have
figured this out instead of having this
cloud hanging over them going on the
training camp he should have already
made the trade by now what is important
what if he's waiting for portland in
that situation with um you don't know
i know you don't but but you know maybe
the timelines
can match because you know as you know
just like in any sport
uh deadlines spur action yeah what if
what if you know
he knows and i'm sure he's got his ear
to the ground that lillard is that's a
situation they're still working on and
that's kind of a ticking
um situation
in portland and he's trying to wait and
two in the bush kind of guy i mean you
can count on dame you can count on the
blazers struggling in the first half
under chelsea builders you can count on
damian lillard just being you know
completely
checked out at at the midway point and i
don't know dame but for what i
understand if dame's in he's in until
he's not and i think it would be
somewhat out of character of damian
lillard to add mid-season
decide get me out of here by the
deadline maybe after the season is is
something all together different right
but maybe maybe that goes that way maybe
that's a big if maybe bradley beal has a
change of heart besides you know what i
i said i liked it here but i changed my
mind get me out of okay but you're
banking on these unknowns burden hands
were two in the bush for me
and so in the meantime your team is
imploding so everybody's looking around
everybody that's interested in ben
simmons whether it's minnesota whether
it's golden state whether sacramento
whoever it is
they're looking at indiana they're
looking at you saying okay you're
driving a hard bargain we'll just wait
we'll just wait you have no choice but
to trade him and your price has to come
down so they're waiting for your
situation implode why you waiting for
somebody else's situation to implode i
would just rather see them get a better
fitting roster around embiid
and move on from the situation and and
and for ben simmons sake
listen i was as hard on him as anybody
after he put up eight six and five in
those last few games in the playoffs
okay
and i have no sympathy for the heat that
he's gotten
for coming up small the way that he did
okay and i get why doc rivers and joel
and b were upset look man you you're
primarily responsible for holding us
back at this point at least on the
offensive end with all the respect what
he does on defense and even from a
passing standpoint okay
i get all of that
he's he's been hung out to drive thrown
under the bus whatever you want to say
he has been the fall guy like let him go
because this is where i do have some
sympathy is like he doesn't need to be
brought back into the situation given
the way last year ended yes he has four
guarantee years left but move on from
him because he would thrive in a
minnesota if minnesota's dreams come
true he's anthony that wasn't called
anthony towns
uh and maybe even the angela russell as
well i pay to see that you know let him
go somewhere where he can thrive because
it ain't in philadelphia he knows it
they know it the rest of the league
knows it we know it move on i look
forward to moving on to your show later
on uh i'll say uh say say hello to
everybody there because i'm coming i
look forward to later on michael thanks
for making this video is that like an
announcement like you come in with the
thunder like you coming
yes i only know one speed michael smith
and it's your way
that's why we see that's why we buy
that's why we don't need to prepare for
you know any other topic you wanna get
into before you let me know you just
spin whatever curveball my way and i'll
try and uh take it out of the park best
i can and then give thumbs up then
thumbs up you know i'll give you a
thumbs down no i'm not that type of guy
it's a positive show today very positive
even hearing that tony romo said that
zach wilson's got the ability of patrick
mahomes and he's going to get there in
the next couple of years not even that's
going to get me into the negative vibes
of a jet fan trying to figure out how
that's not going to work i won't do it
i'm just going to take it
a lot of people said that right you just
said what rommel said
yeah i've heard him say i've heard them
say that he's got abilities like you
know like he can throw on the run and
that's what you need to do like you know
like it's never been he looks and
reminds me of mahomes and he can be a
top five talent and get there in the
next couple of years didn't didn't see
that one coming from roma i think we're
going to talk about that just real real
quick i know you got to go real quick
i'm sorry this is a dumb question that's
not
you are in fact and i should know this
i'm sorry i should know this but you are
in fact uh nets jets knicks correct no i
am i am actually jets yankees knicks
um i am still jets um yankees literally
every day we have the yes network on in
our house they know every they know the
entire
my kids know the entire lineup on the s
network and i have met jeff mix right
well it's because i come from i'm a 52
year old man and anybody in my age group
used to uh root for the teams from a
certain stadium so the jets and mets
played in the same stadium and the nets
were out on long island at the time so
it was a jets nets mets combination it
was yankees giants and then nick's
combination even though the knicks
didn't play there but i i grew up my
brother was a met fan and so i saw the
mets early on in my life and knew i was
never going to get a championship from
them certainly when i was a jet fan and
hopped off that train and then when um
when the knicks
security dragged charles oakley out of
madison square garden and uh james dolan
could not be um bothered to move an inch
from his position with his schmecky uh
uh
i guess of scarf holding his styrofoam
cup of coffee that was it for me i was
at i'm i'm i'm out you know i'll watch
him i'll watch him i love thibodeau i
love thibodeaux i love obviously what
julius randle has done with his career i
i like
iq was fun to watch but i'm out i'm out
i'm out are you brooklyn then
i'm not i'm not i am uh no i'm not
brooklyn i'm i'm i'm a man without a
team i'm a man without a team
i'm all i'm all 30 clubs that's what i'm
about right you know with that well i
was trying to find out we should clown
the mets with you or talk seriously
about the nets as a suffering family
you set the tone and i will i will fill
in the gaps i'll do whatever i need to
do i'll call you i appreciate you
looking forward thank
thank you as well that was the home and
the other day later on is the home uh
love it it is uh brother for another
with michael smith and michael holly i
will be there
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here